now so how will the doj's never-ending
anti-trump Witch Hunt impact the
Republican primary especially now that
the GOP field is growing with former
Trump vice president Mike Pence jumping
in Trump hater Chris Christie entering
the race here with more former Arkansas
Governor Mike Huckabee and former
director of strategic Communications uh
Trump uh Pence 2020 and former Pence
press secretary Mark Lotter
I think he had two different cases here
uh Mark will go to you tonight and start
with you and that is you know Mike Pence
was the VP
in the case of Chris Christie he left
office with I believe a 14 approval
rating and he seems to have indicated he
only wants to run for run one reason and
that's the bludgeon Trump not a
particularly inspiring campaign slogan
no not at all and you know look this is
a one-man race for the for the 20 uh for
the GOP nomination and if you're anyone
not named uh Trump DeSantis has got a
huge mountain to climb all of the other
candidates have a Mount Everest to climb
and if I'm one of those other campaigns
I'm hoping that Chris Christie is going
to throw Haymakers and say the things I
don't want to say because that's the
only way you're going to try to close
the gap but to be honest with you Sean
the only thing I can think of when I
hear of Chris Christie is I think of
that beach picture and you just can't
unsee you cannot see it like you can't
unsee the Romney I'm sorry the Obama hug
during the Romney race uh and you really
can't uh forget about Bridge gate
although obviously that case I believe
was tossed out in the end on appeal
governor do you see any of these
candidates making Headway here and what
impact do you think if this in fact
happens and is an indictment on what we
believe would be a process crime does
that impact Donald Trump's popularity
with the Republican party and maybe the
country at Large
yeah I think his popularity goes up and
his numbers go up people see what's
going on people aren't stupid and they
clearly understand that this is an
attempt to destroy Donald Trump on a
personal level so they don't have to
deal with him politically and I feel
that they're making a huge mistake and
everything they've done so far has
backfired it's almost like watching a
roadrunner cartoon in Wiley Coyote
continues to try to use some Acme
Dynamite it just isn't working but I
want to agree with my friend Mark Lotter
he certainly Nails it Chris Christie is
really in this not because he has a
vision for being president and I think
many of the other candidates do and
they're good people but Chris Christie
is a bitter old guy who is angry at
Donald Trump here's the problem Chris
Christie can't get over one thing that
will destroy him and that's Christopher
Wray people need to remember that it was
Chris Christie who urged Donald Trump to
put Christopher Ray in his FBI director
and we all know how that's turned out so
if there's any reason we can't trust
Chris Christie's judgment and would not
want him in the White House
just remember Christopher Ray that's all
let me ask you about let me ask you
about this Mike I'll give you the first
shot at it
um if you're Donald Trump he has
indicated he's probably not going to be
involved in primary debates if you were
advising him would you tell them to take
part in them or not
it's not going to help him necessarily
because he's 30 points ahead he can
pretty much do what he wants to do but
it won't hurt him either I mean one
thing I think everybody saw in 2016 he
can go on that stage with everybody
who's had years of debate experience and
he wipes the floor because he's just
freewheeling enough that he's not a
candidate goes out there with all his
note cards indelibly imprinted on the
back of his head he goes in there and
free wheels and basically wipes every
person off that stage and it won't hurt
him but I think he probably can create
his own venues and not have to go look I
think the debates are a joke I think
their game show I don't think that they
have any validity anymore it's all about
I think they're bad anchors
uh no they're horrible and and I beg the
RNC went to a Chicago meeting and said
take these things away from the networks
don't let them control it because let
the candidates run the debates let them
speak their mind and give them a certain
amount of time everybody gets exactly
the same I think it'd be about real
quick yes smart or not smart for Trump
to debate
I'd wait until it thins out a little bit
and until you get uh just down to a few
candidates so they're not all piling up
on you
yeah okay good advice thank you both hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else